one of the really interesting
perspectives that your book takes
on a system like this is to see them not
to compare something like this to humans
but to compare it to animals of how we
see animals can you kind of try to again
sneak up try to explain why this analogy
is better than the human analogy the
analogy of robots as animals yeah and it
gets trickier with the language stuff
but we'll get into that too
um I think that animals are a really
great thought experiment when we're
thinking about Ai and Robotics because
again this comparing them to humans that
leads us down the wrong path both
because it's not accurate but also I
think for the future we don't want that
we want something that's a supplement
but I think animals because we've used
them throughout history for so many
different things we we domesticated them
not because they do what we do but
because what they do is different and
that's useful and I it's just like
whether we're talking about
companionship whether we're talking
about work integration whether we're
talking about responsibility for harm
there's just so many things we can draw
on in that history from these entities
that can sense think make autonomous
decisions and learn that are applicable
to how we should be thinking about
robots in Ai and and the point of the
book is not that they're the same thing
that animals and robots are the same
obviously there are tons of differences
there like you can't you can't have a
conversation with a squirrel right but
the the point you do it all the time oh
really by the way squirrels are the
cutest I project so much on squirrels I
wonder what their inner life is
um I suspect they're much bigger
[ __ ] than we imagine really like if
it was a giant squirrel it would [ __ ]
you over so fast if you had the chance
it would take everything you own it
would eat all your stuff because it's
small and the Furry Tail the furry tale
is a
is uh
is a weapon against human consciousness
and cognition it wins us over that's
what cats do too cats out I'll competed
squirrels
and dogs like yeah dogs no dogs have
love cats are have no soul they I'm just
kidding people get so angry I talk [ __ ]
about cats that I love cats anyway uh so
yeah uh yeah you're you're describing
all the different kinds of animals that
get domesticated
and it's a really interesting idea that
it's not just sort of pets there's all
kinds of domestication going on they all
have all kinds of uses yes like the uh
Ox that you
propose might be
at least historically one of the most
useful domesticated animals it was a
game changer because it revolutionized
like what people could do economically
Etc so I I mean just like robots They're
Gonna Change they're going to change
things economically they're going to
change Landscapes like cities might even
get rebuilt around autonomous vehicles
or drones or delivery robots like I
think just the same ways that animals
have really shifted society and Society
has adapted also to like socially
accepting animals as pets
um I think we're going to see very
similar things with robots so I think
it's a useful analogy it's not a perfect
one but I think it's
it helps us get away from this idea that
robots can shoot or will replace people
if you remember what are some
interesting uses of animals ferrets for
example oh yeah the ferrets they they
still do this they use ferrets to go
into narrow spaces that people can't go
into like a pipe or like they'll use in
the wrong electrical wire I think they
did that for princess dies her wedding
there's so many weird ways that work
we've used animals and still use animals
for things that robots can't do like the
dolphins that they used in the in the
military I think the I think Russia
still has Dolphins and the US still has
dolphins in their navies
um
mind detection looking for lost
underwater equipment
some rumors about like using them for
weaponry
which which I think Russia's like sure
believe that and America's like no no we
don't do that who knows but they started
doing that in like the 60s 70s they
started training these Dolphins because
they were like oh dolphins have this
amazing echolocation system that we
can't replicate with machines and
they're trainable so we're going to use
them for all the stuff that we can't do
with machines or by ourselves and
they've tried to phase out the Dolphins
I know the US has like invested a lot of
money in trying to make robots do the
Mind detection but like you were saying
there are some things that the robots
are good at and there's some things that
biological creatures are better at so
they still have the Dolphins so there's
also pigeons of course oh yeah pigeons
oh my gosh there's so many examples the
pitch I mean
the pigeons were the original hobby
photography drone they also carried mail
for thousands of years letting people
communicate with each other in new ways
so the thing that I like about the
animal analogies they have all these
physical abilities but also sensing
abilities that we just we don't have and
like that's that's just so useful and
that's that's robots right robots have
physical abilities they can help us lift
things or do things that we're not
physically capable of they can also
sense things
it's just I just feel like I still feel
like it's a really good analogy and
really strong and it works because it's
people are familiar with it
what about companionship and when we
start to think about like cats and dogs
like pets that seem to serve no purpose
whatsoever except the social connection
yeah I mean this
newer thing
at least in the United States like dogs
used to have like they used to have a
purpose they used to be guard dogs or
they had some sort of function and then
at some point they became just part of
the family
um and I
it's it's so interesting how there's
some animals that we've treated as
workers some that we've treated as
objects some that we eat and some that
are parts of our families and that
that's different across cultures and I'm
convinced that we're going to see the
same thing with robots
um where people are going to develop
strong emotional connections to certain
robots that they relate to either
culturally or or personally emotionally
and then there's going to be other
robots that we don't treat the same way
I wonder does that have to do more with
the culture and the people or the robot
design is there interplay between the
two like why did dogs and cats
out compete
ox and
I don't know what else like farm animals
to to really get inside the home and get
inside our hearts yeah I mean people
point to the fact that dogs are very
genetically flexible and
um they can evolve much more quickly
than other animals and so they
evolutionary biologists think that dogs
evolved to be more appealing to us and
then once we learned how to breed them
we started breeding them to be more
appealing to us too which is not
something that we necessarily would be
able to do with cows although we've bred
them to make more milk for us
so but part of it is also culture I mean
they're cultures where people eat dogs
still today and then there's other
cultures where we're like oh no that's
terrible we would never do that and so I
think there's a lot of different
elements that play in I wonder if
there's good because I understand dogs
because they use their eyes they're able
to communicate affection all those kinds
of things it's really interesting what
dogs do there's a whole conferences and
dog Consciousness and cognition and all
that kind of stuff now cats is a mystery
to me
because they seem to not give a [ __ ]
about the human but they're warm and
fluffy
but they but they're also passive
aggressive so they're at the same time
they're like they're dismissive of of
you in some sense I think some people
like that some people like that about
people
yeah they want they want the push and
pull over of a relationship they don't
want loyalty or unconditional love that
does that means they haven't earned it
yeah
yeah
and maybe that says a lot more about the
people than it does about the animal oh
yeah we all need therapy yeah
so I'm judging harshly to people that
have cats or or the people that have
dogs
maybe the people that have dogs need are
desperate for attention and
unconditional love and they're unable to
to
um
to sort of struggle uh to earn
meaningful connections
um I don't know maybe people are talking
about you and your robot pets in the
same way
yeah that's uh
it is kind of sad there's just the
robots everywhere but he's I mean I'm
joking about it being said because I
think it's kind of beautiful I think
robots are
uh beautiful in the same way that pets
are even children in that like they
capture some kind of magic of uh social
robots
they have the capacity to have the same
kind of magic of connection
um I don't know what that is like um
when they're brought to life and they
move around
the way they make me feel I'm pretty
convinced
is as as you know
they will make billions of people feel
like I I don't think I'm like some weird
robotics guy I'm not I mean you are but
not in this way not in this way I mean I
just I can put on my like normal human
hat and just see this oh this is like
there's a lot of possibility there of
something cool just like with dogs what
is it why are we so into dogs or cats
like it's like that it's way different
than us
it is it's like drooling all over the
place with its tongue out and it's like
what it's like a weird creature that
used to be a wolf why are we into this
thing well dogs can
either Express or mimic a lot of
emotions that we recognize
um and I think that's a big thing like a
lot of the magic of animals and robots
is our own self-projection and the
easier it is for us to
see ourselves in something and project
human emotions or qualities or traits
onto it the more we'll relate to it and
then you also have the movement of
course I think that's also really that's
why I'm so interested in physical robots
because that's I think the visceral
magic of them I think we're I mean
there's there's research showing that
we're probably biologically hardwired to
respond to autonomous movement in our
physical space because we've had to
watch out for Predators or whatever the
reason is
um and so animals and robots are very
appealing to us as these autonomously
moving things that we view as agents
instead of objects
I mean I I love the moment which is I've
been particularly working on which is
when a robot like the cowboy hat uh is
doing its own thing and then
uh it recognizes you I mean the way a
dog does and it it looks like this and
the the moment of recognition like
you're walking say you're walking an
airport on the street
and there's just you know hundreds of
strangers but then you see somebody you
know and that like
where you wake up to like
uh that excitement of seeing somebody
you know and saying hello and all that
kind of stuff that's a magical moment
like uh I think especially with the dog
it makes you feel noticed and heard and
and loved like that somebody looks at
you and recognizes you that that it
matters that you exist yeah you feel
seen yeah and that's a cool feeling and
I I honestly think robots can get that
feeling oh yeah totally currently Alexa
I mean one of the downsides of these
systems is they don't
there's servants they like uh
part of the you know they're trying to
maintain privacy I suppose uh but
I don't feel seen with Alexa
right I think that's going to change I
think you're right and I think that
that's that's the game changing changing
nature of things like these large
language learning models and the fact
that these companies are investing in
embodied versions that move around of
Alexa like Astro can I just say yeah I
haven't is that out is this I mean it's
out you can't just like buy one
commercially yet but you can apply for
one